un situation exceptionnelle solution
exceptionnelle pour la première fois le
tribunal de commerce de fort de france
autorise une reprise d'activité après
avoir prononcé la liquidation d'une
entreprise une réponse favorable à la
requête déposée par le procureur de la
république en personne un nouveau sursis
est donc accordée à france antilles
jusqu'au 10 mars pour laisser au patron
de free le temps de déposer son offre
c'est une personne qui avait déjà été
plus ou moins intéressé par les
activités de france antilles donc il
doit avoir certainement eu connaissance
en fait si vous voulez de
l'environnement et donc en fait le délai
il est ce qu'il est mais surtout
permettre après effectivement de
consulter les salariés personnel sur
l'offre qui va être présenté une fin que
ça représente et pour qu'ils puissent
émettre leur avis les 235 salariés n'y
croyait plus il y à 24 heures encore ils
surveillaient leur boîte aux lettres
dans la tente de leur courrier de
licenciement
leurs nerfs sont donc de nouveau mis à
rude épreuve on est vraiment passés par
toutes les phases des émotions la colère
la tristesse les pleurs la déprime enfin
c'est vraiment que de tout et c'est vrai
que là on s'attendait de notifier de
nous les sentiments ledit prochain et là
on apprend que c'est suspendu que sa
relance sa relance encore sa re joue
encore le jeu de cartes sa relance
l'espoir en tout cas nous on croit en
cette presse écrite on a envie et on a
envie de poursuivre l'aventuré nature
surtout envie que la martinique retrouve
un journal les procédures de
licenciement sont interrompus les
salaires seront intégralement versés
pendant la période de prolongation
le tribunal de commerce lance
parallèlement un nouvel appel d'offres
jusqu'au lundi 2 mars
le temps est désormais compté c'est
court mais en même temps hier on nous
avait dit ça on allait on n'avait rien
donc c'est court et en même temps si je
pense que si par exemple xavier niel se
positionne il a peut-être déjà un projet
derrière la tête
bon ils savaient très bien que son offre
était hors délai donc déjà c
une procédure exceptionnelle puisqu'il
ya un enjeu important en terme social et
puis en termes de pluralité aussi
d'informations sur nos territoires
donc à lui de faire en sorte d'être prêt
avant le 2 mars
il restera à connaître les détails de
l'offre attendu par le tribunal et les
employés ces derniers s'attendent à ce
qu'elle s'accompagne d'un plan social
pour ramener le groupe à l' équilibre
financier et peut-être entrevoir un
avenir plus radieux pour le quotidien
des antilles